alright let's talk about the environment
there were two studies released this
week announcing that a large ice sheet
in West Antarctica is beginning to melt
which might start the process of
sea-level rising not good we've got a
bit of information for you so this study
from the University of Washington
concluded that the collapse of the
weights glacier is already underway this
process could be completed within the
next few centuries and would cause the
ocean to rise by nearly 2 feet because
that glacier is currently acting as a
barrier for the rest of the ice sheet
its collapse could ultimately trigger a
10 to 13 foot rise in global sea levels
and we've got some info from a NASA
study also the study predicted a 4-foot
rise in sea levels as the melting rate
accelerates in the Amundsen sea sector
winds in the Antarctic are pulling warm
water to the surface and causing the ice
to melt global warming is a contributing
factor but not the sole cause natural
non human induced changes in climate
across the globe might also be at fault
so I wanted to start with that part and
I'm gonna go to our science and green
person first so what they're basically
saying here is that this is a combo of
manmade climate change and that things
are just changing on Earth just because
of natural processes is that accepted in
the scientific community at this point
that there's two things happening here
it's something where you know when you
get down into the nuance of these
studies they're talking about you know
there is the natural processes you know
the natural oscillations that the ocean
currents and the winds go through and
global temperatures you know but there's
also then that human-induced influence
that kicks it up a notch so what that's
kind of what though so you believe in
climate change is that what you're doing
I accept the science of climate change
absolutely I do but you know what I
think is most shocking about this is
it's part of it is your definition of
collapse you know when when the public
the general public hears the word
collapsed they think oh my god it's
going right now and when they're talking
about it in science terms in this
specific thing with glaciers they're
talking about you know there is a point
after which it is not ever going to
return that's irreversible and it will
lead to the eventual collapse you know
so there is scientifically it's more of
a slow collapse obviously it's going to
take you know they estimate about 200
years or so at the minimum for this
glaciar the Thwaites glacier - to melt
and that is going to then be the issue
with the West Antarctic Ice Sheet which
is you know massive yeah it covers half
that continent and that's the big
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
years but it's still going to be very
important for all coastal cities am I
making this up it's something like 20
times the size of Manhattan yeah it's
huge I mean when you realize Antarctica
is a continent an actual continent and I
forget how big it is in comparison to
say the North American continent but it
is it is darn huge and it is going to be
a problem you know when you know we're
not just talking about this specific
glacier being the only one that's
melting it just happens to be the one
that they looked at in this particular
study that's melting quite quickly
we have glaciers melting all over the
world and we have Greenland ice melt as
well so all of these together
cumulatively
are going to raise sea levels as well
and there's really when it's when you
get to this irreversible place you know
they're saying we don't see any way that
these ice sheets are going to be stopped
there's no mountain range underneath
there there's nothing to stop it so as
part of the problem that this just
happened so slowly as desi saying I
think that's sort of we deal with things
especially our politicians we don't deal
with issues of today so we definitely
aren't going to deal with issues of
tomorrow so as part of state it's just
happening so slowly that one day it's
just gonna keep rise and keep rising
keep rising and then we'll just be
swimming and ever I'll go oh we always
swam because I don't remember anybody
that didn't swim Waterworld will really
be more like actual history yeah I think
that yeah you know unfortunately maybe
the clock for the climate change science
it has been so sort of hijacked as a
political tool that I think when people
see it even if there is science behind
it or or whatever they're they're very
quick to say no this is definitely just
somebody using it to trump up some kind
of agenda and and I think that that's
unfortunate because indeed you know we
have seen so much evidence come out to
say that you know there is a certain
point where we are doing things that are
harmful to the to the country the
country just it just a missed America to
the world
however on that note I did look at some
of the sea levels if you look at Los
Angeles in a hundred years if we are 200
years or so if we have a ten-foot
increase in sea levels the only people
that will be affected are those living
in Marina del Rey
let's be honest you really wanted to get
there I could see it coming
I could see it coming is part of this so
I obviously believe in climate change I
believe these things are happening but
as part of this just sort of what human
evolution is all about like we're gonna
destroy this earth I feel like it's just
sort of the way evolution is we're gonna
streisand that we're gonna go somewhere
else and that's why we're exploring
space because everyone knows we're gonna
do this well there's a couple different
things if I may first of all I would I
would recommend that you say I accept
the science because if you say I believe
in climate even price-wise a religion
and you know and that's [ __ ] and
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about you accept the
science or you do not excited mend it
right now I accept the science there you
go but then when it comes to human
nature I think you are absolutely right
that there is a part of evolution you
know where essentially species and you
know obviously we're the most advanced
sentient species that's walked the earth
but previously let's just say that yeah
we can actually think about what we're
doing unlike you know most most species
and what tends to happen in nature is
that a species will expand into its
territory and expand into its range
until it uses up all the resources and
you know once it uses up all the
resources Nature has a pretty you know
Swift and efficient way of cutting that
species back to size so that it fits
within its environment so we're kind of
following along with that same natural
progression we do have the choice though
we can at any time stop that and I think
you know that's the whole point of
Sciences you know using science to be
able to predict stuff otherwise why
bother yeah do you think science is
having a little bit of a comeback right
now I think cosmos on Fox and it's
getting some good buzz there is a sense
of like we need to be a little more
scientifically literate in this country
and then stories like this right I think
sort of know that don't call it a
comeback I mean I think that science for
whatever reason has like this really bad
rap yeah which is really strange because
everything we get it seems it seems so
obvious
about saying I certainly hope so you
know as a child of science I would hope
so I think it is definitely more popular
now than it used to be not just with
cosmos but you know that Facebook I
[ __ ] love science those people you
know I think with CSI the TV show people
sort of got interested in the science
science you know and I think that's
that's popularizing the concept of
science it's popularizing the ideas of a
scientific method and I think with that
comes more engagement from the public
although we know we do have a problem
with a very strong effort culturally by
a certain you know a group of Evan
Jellicle right-wingers who insist that
you know we have to include religion in
our science classes and you know we've
had to beat back that particular
onslaught periodically since the 20s so
that's the part that I understand and
this will be the final thought on this
like the part of these people that
simply don't believe in the evidence I
don't get what their faith has to do
with this why can't you have faith in a
higher being or whatever your religious
beliefs are and still believe that
humans are doing things and I really
think that it comes down to skepticism
based on on what I just talked about
earlier which is there there are people
who use it for agenda you know point
making when you are on the opposite side
of that if you're conservative you see
manmade climate change historically
being an issue that is sort of
championed by the left and downplayed by
the right so it's not even about whether
or not it's real or not it's about this
is this is something that somebody else
says on my opposing team so I'm gonna
I'm gonna disagree about the endless
bipolar nature tied into your tribal
identity I mean people have a cultural
identity and they tend to filter the
news and any other information they get
through that cultural identity and so if
it doesn't fit with that cultural
identity then they reject it although I
will say there are evangelical Christian
Scientists you know there's a climate
scientist named Katharine Hayhoe
who was doing a great job of trying to I
know she's the most adorable climate
scientist that has ever she's a cutest
thing and she also is able to sort of be
an ambassador of science to these
religious groups and say hey
you don't have to believe that the world
is more than 6,000 years old an elder to
understand physics you know you can say
that hey God created the world he might
also have created physics yeah and so
we're just figuring out ways that we
don't we just get to a place where we
can agree that like we don't know
everything science doesn't explain
everything and religion certainly can't
Andy we cannot get to that place but
we've gotta move on